hi my name is Otto Silva we developed a
notebook for modeling co2 sequestration
globally CEO of phantom works which is a
company consulting company automatically
thank you very much for coming to the
toy stock on carbon sequestration and
storage we I need to begin with full
disclosure we set up a very very
ambitious goal to try and simulate the
capture of co2 in the whole atmosphere
as we as we used up several gigabytes of
data we started dialing down the
resolution and the and the actual
network for the for the simulation of
the of the amount of carbon
sequestration facilities as projected by
the number of sites where the where the
co2 is being generated we we actually
couldn't handle the whole project no so
we we settled on using
Wolfram's capabilities we we used a very
large computer at unum in Mexico and it
it actually couldn't handle that amount
of calculation and and memory so that's
before I begin that's I mean my
apologies for that
but we at least got to use Wolfram
language for displaying and showing the
data the geolocation of the data and we
found some very interesting features of
the distribution of co2 on planet Earth
as well as the distribution of
sequestration facilities which
which are in actual use so that's where
we focus our our attention on
so we began by using this data which is
publicly available there there's a whole
bunch of sites on the Internet where you
can download the data on cl2 there is
the IPCC which is probably the best most
curated place for it and where you can
find data from 2000 and from 1972 to
2000 and 2012 actually 2019 which is
this year so it's several years about 40
years of data that they have available
so we import this data we generate the
the data from the from coordinates that
the data corresponds to latitude
longitude and co2 concentration and it's
normalized by by year so that you can
actually see the actual amount of co2
and with a sub percentage of the total
and this is one of the one of images we
got we we can see here that it's mainly
on land of course but we can see all the
also the
the right the co2 generated by
transportation on the seasonal and
transportation might see roads globally
another issue that we found interesting
is that the remain according to this
data
the main generation of co2 is in Asia
mostly in India and China and also a
huge increase has been detected on on
Africa this this picture is normalized
to show the the amount as percent
percentage increase we also use these
capabilities to show the Geo position of
the of ya the places where the there are
the most emissions of co2 that's the red
dots this is over a gigabyte of data
which is summarized here and here we
accounting top 10 sites where the co2
concentration is is greatest and as we
said it's mainly on China India and this
part of Africa where we can find these
concentrations there is also the
countries know if we go by resolution of
countries where these emissions are
greatest we can see that China again
China and India our big generation one
of the issues with these
with the fact is that it will carbon
emissions will all we will only rise in
the future so it's a big concern to have
carbon sequestration facilities
distributed with some kind of logic
later we're going to see the the actual
places for carbon sequestration
facilities are located here we can see
the yeah again the normalized version of
hot spots of co2 intensity activity and
this is another view with with this
Albers projection again it is the
concentration in the last year correct
yeah yep
per year yes so that's the constraint a
concentration using the data from 2018
I'm sorry yes part parts per million
yeah it's about four it's about 400
parts per million I'm sorry
yeah it's we have the range over here so
the thing show you the difference and
concentration I think there is a scale
over here as you know we can check that
really quickly yeah sorry right now yeah
champagne you know yeah this is the
actual distribution of co2 sequest
sequestration facilities show you that
so here we there's a database of the
facilities available for carbon
sequestration globally they are mainly
concentrated in in the US and Canada
here's where the tar sands are done
yes facilities facilities which are
currently working number that that's
account count of facilities I mean
there's a lot of in California and Texas
there is virtually none in Latin America
there are some in China and in India
there is in Australia there's a few in
Canada also and yeah this is a global
problem but it's some in the Arabian
Peninsula even though it's a global
problem it's currently not as
treated as it should this also due to
the fact that it this these are
expensive facilities no so here we we
made a plot with the different kinds of
of carbon sequestration for facilities
there are for instance there is a
threshold for which power absorption co2
absorption is achieved it's that's why
it's mainly located where the power is
being generated rather than just sprayed
all over just last week there was a an
article published by MIT where there's a
new technology that's being researched
on that captures co2 at low
concentrations but that's still as a
development technology it's not quietly
used right now one of the problems with
these facilities is the fact that they
require energy to be used so they they
sit side by side with power generation
facilities know so they imitate the the
issue but that's why here are some it's
classified as power distribution
some of them use carbon a call this is
the distribution of these technologies
and mainly in North America and in in
the United Kingdom and also there's some
industrial sites which are more widely
spread I mean in the world and
this is just a carbon capture
sequestration mainly in in oil States in
Texas and in Canada mostly and this is
director capture which as we said it's
just sequestration of co2 directly from
the atmosphere regardless of where the
concentration is big enough to be
sequestered one of the issues also is
the fact that you need to store these
co2 in the ground so it doesn't filter
out to the atmosphere again otherwise
you're just shifting the problem away
know if it leaks out in two hundred
years then you're going to have an issue
in two hundred years time so it's that
that's why the geological location is
also critical I mean it's not just put
it whenever there is wherever there is a
source of co2 you have to consider the
ground on which these facilities is
facility is located and make sure that
it's appropriate for it to store the co2
which is which has been captured and it
remains there for the longest time
possible cause leakage even if it's 1%
per year it's it's going to be an issue
yes the water and soil you mean on the
sea
I'm sorry which in these categories okay
as far as I know that that's not
including this in these categories in
this database
no they they're different in size the
the yeah it's some tons per year it's
actually some megatons per year but yeah
yeah I the website there's yeah each of
these has a very specific each of these
has a very specific capability and it's
all shown in in each individual side of
it so it's it varies a lot yes it's a
fraction of 1%
it's about point zero three yeah yeah
it's we need about three thousand times
the actual installed capacity to to
mitigate with current technology I mean
it's it's in the order of thousands of
times what we currently have installed
to actually have some impact even even
if we if we have carbon neutral
emissions there is an impact of at least
five hundred years in in the climate I
mean if we stopped
the emissions of co2 today for some
magical reason still the the the impact
of these in the long term is already
being done because of the heating of the
ocean and the interchange with the
atmosphere so so it's a it's a big
effort but it but again the economic
consequences of status quo is a has a
bigger impact even in the short term
then just doing nothing business as
usual scenario so basically that's the
material I I wanted to share with you
and I'd like to know if you have any
further questions or it's the short
answer is no it's not a business I mean
it should be offset by by I know tax
incentives and policy that really helps
mitigate politic the political vision of
this it's very important because it has
some major impact on on the actual
practices that take place
if you think about its actual economic
activity that's being promoted by this
it's an infrastructure project have a
possible impact even though it cuts
costs money it generates revenue as well
yeah otherwise the purpose is defeated
yeah all these project all these
projects are in that order of magnitude
of G he probably does because it's too
dense to be yeah - the only seafarers
yeah but it's yeah it's interesting to
note that human activities it's just
shown very clearly clearly they're not
[Laughter]
on the sea just occasionally yeah that's
that's what we were saying you know as
far as I know these are satellite
measurements
no we haven't we
we used a supercomputer in Nam in Mexico
in crater which is used for yes yes it
was we need several more terabytes in
primary to achieve this this goal but we
could also just diminish the resolution
and but then we we didn't really have
other than the obvious result which is
put it right next to the I mean we
wanted to get to the to the source we
wanted to to have a network but it never
showed with the resolution was so low
that it only gave the trivial solution
of
of placing on top of the sources so that
that's why we didn't achieve the
original goal which was to have a
network effect yes that's right so we
need to match both geological and
atmospheric and and have a network
effect but that we couldn't match if
that's a good question it there there's
also a large I to be honest I don't know
there's also very large concentration in
Central America for some reason I mean
it's not heavily industrial and it's
also not heavily oil producer but there
is really as large as in Mexico or
higher which is puzzling because there's
really as far as we know not much going
on there as far as co2 emissions but
perfect apparently there is some issue
going on China and India are really not
surprising definitely definitely
yeah but cattle and no no not we'll call
that meeting yeah okay
that there any other come at this data
and notebook are of course available
with you if you wish so there's nothing
else you know it's a it's really not a
research project it it was not intended
to as such it was just something we
collaborated with some researchers with
autonomy and my company Mexico which is
quantum works with algorithm design for
companies so the piece is just something
we we try to put together
yes definitely
yeah yeah we were on that path yep it's
worth it's worth working right but we
need more resources I mean we yeah but
there is a job just in our research
facility in Mexico there is a physics
Applied Physics Center right next to
geological research center so we haven't
I'm in the research well I collaborate
with the physics department but not with
the geophysics or the Joley
so when we just need to have a
conversation and just make that happen
but we were on our path to to achieve
that well thank you very much
[Applause]